hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmfccontrol
ca.l2-3.12.2 develop and Implement plans
of action designed to correct
deficiencies and reduce or eliminate
vulnerabilities in organizational
systems
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist SP 800 171 compliant
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload I got great news for you you
found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions we can help you
transform into your company's on-call
compliance hero if you haven't done it
yet reach right down there smash that
subscribe button it really helps us out
and again lets us know that we're doing
the right thing for you guys so again if
you've been watching our control videos
send some love our way hit the like
button and definitely smash that
subscribe button so you can check out
all the videos
now let's jump into it so uh we're
talking about cmmccontrol
ca.l2-3.12.2 develop and Implement plans
of action designed to correct
efficiencies and reduce or eliminate
vulnerabilities in organizational
systems well this one's pretty easy and
straightforward okay you better have a
poem and if you don't have a poem or a
plan of action uh with Milestones uh
well then well you're not compliant to
begin with so forget about cmmc
certification you're not even at the
start finish line yet right uh so again
not just any poem it better have any
temporary deficiencies you have along
with your original Baseline deficiencies
from where from when you started so yes
your poem is part of your Baseline
documentation requirement and again this
is something a lot of people don't
understand when it talks about the idea
of Baseline documentation it considers
the idea that you're compliant as a part
of your Baseline so again your assist
your system security plan your plan of
action Milestones all the network
inventory stuff there's so much involved
in Baseline documentation just show that
again if something happens you have
record of it so again your poem also is
a place where you should be tracking all
of your changes yes I know the form they
give you from the government is really
not that friendly for tracking changes
but you know what it doesn't matter
because that's the way the government
says do it so that's how we do it so
again track your changes in your poem
and again it is kind of that forever
living document of what you've gone
through and what you've done very
important to prove you are performing
the actions required of you which
includes keeping up with your plan of
action with Milestones as time goes on
so again you want to be able to show
that assessor in one big document hey
here's everything that was wrong here's
everything we did to fix it and that's
kind of a quick summary of what the poem
needs to be so let's jump into what the
assessors are looking for on this one
so we're looking for three key pieces of
information if you're an assessor okay
one you want to determine if
deficiencies and vulnerabilities to be
addressed by the plan of action are
identified now where would they where
would they be identified this one's
pretty simple the answer is hey go look
at our poem and of course for assessment
Point number two you're probably gonna
get the same answer right determine if a
plan of action is developed to correct
identified deficiencies and reduce or
eliminate identified vulnerabilities
here again all we have to do is say go
look at the poem everything you're
looking for should be in there so again
make sure you're doing all your proper
documentation
final assessment point is to determine
if the plan of action is implemented to
correct identified deficiencies and
reduce or eliminate identified
vulnerabilities here again your plan of
actual Milestone should have notes on
exactly what you did to remediate those
vulnerabilities where are you going to
put in the plan you know what I got to
tell you there's no defined field for it
in the table that comes from the
government you can either add one to
your own spreadsheet or what I like to
do is we just simply make footnotes in
the document so that wherever you are in
the document wherever the deficiency is
again what you did to solve it is there
and then you're changing your ultimate
answer to it's completed versus a
temporary efficiency so again
remediation of poem items will be
evidence within the it ticketing system
as well so this is another key piece
which is it may not just be good enough
to show what you did in a summary they
may want to actually see evidence that
things were done in your ticketing
system so keep that in mind and again
always keep great notes about how you're
changing your system very important now
at on-call we work with people just like
you all right defense Contractors Supply
Chain people in the defense industry uh
who have had this D fars nist itar and
cmmc compliance stuff dropped in their
laps like a seagull on a sunny day we
teach you how to level up and be the
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company eliminating gaps gray areas and
getting this solved all while showing
you how to leverage compliance as your
secret weapon to land more Defense work
with higher profit margins now that's
what becoming an on-call compliance hero
can do for you if you're looking for
more help getting compliant our
compliance experts are always on call
for you you can visit
cmmccomplianceecrets.com do it right now
open up another tab CMC
complianceeekers.com check it out or you
can always check out the Bible below for
links to get help right now okay love
the content we're putting out here for
you help us out with a big thumbs up on
that like button or even better smash
the Subscribe button it really means a
lot to us when we get those
subscriptions it just kind of brightens
our day all right uh and again you want
to be subscribed so you get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliance nerves roll it out until next
compliance tip my friends stay safe and
secure out there hit us in the comments
below to let us know what you'd like to
know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance I'll
see you on the next one
[Music]